one of the great things about the game
is just that it's a game and at the same
time students are picking up so many
valuable life skills things like how to
solve complex problems how to face
adversity how to realize that challenges
in life much like challenges in chess
can be overcome by using your brain it's
amazing to watch these kids who when
they're not at the chessboard are normal
little kid but when you see them sit
down at the board it really is like
somebody has flipped a switch and they
focus and they concentrate and these are
all character traits that we're trying
to further enhance and develop in these
students I've been here since day one
and I will tell you that we had no idea
just how successful some of these
programs would be the chest campus here
really is a treasure and people are
coming down almost daily to experience
programming at each institution chess is
so broad and we try to engage all
audiences especially children since
they're the ones who are learning how to
play at young ages and are so
enthusiastic about the game last year
and we partnered with the magic house
and did an exhibition called kings
queens and castles that is touring the
united states it's a Hall of Fame we've
exhibited over a hundred artists we've
exhibited thousands of chess sets we've
educated so many people 60,000 people
have come through our door and over a
hundred st. Louis schools we're making a
big impact on st. Louis it's important
to reach out into the community to reach
students who otherwise would not come
down to the chess club and especially
students in schools where they maybe
don't have the same benefits that other
students do the ultimate goal of the
chess club and scholastic center of st.
Louis is to introduce chess into every
singular school from my own experience I
got to see students decrease out of
classroom time behaviors got better
academic focus and stamina got better
and that was across the range of
students so even students that had been
very low performing academically started
to perform better and students that were
high performing academically performed
even better than that some kids struggle
with reading writing that sort of thing
to have them have the chance to
demonstrate the intellectual powers in
what universe
we recognized as a thinking game I think
it's a really great opportunity one of
the things I actually love about chest
is it teaches critical thinking looking
at the game the patience of the game all
of it is things that are truly violence
that's in this community with all the
distraction that they have whether it's
home like whatever else is going on
around them this kind of slows the world
down and lets them focus just for that
moment while playing the game of chess
she makes you feel happy and it makes
them great think about it I like the way
the chisme mop won't think patient and
concentration focus those were all
things that you could see firsthand that
week after week students got stronger
and stronger in and they showed those
skills not just in chess but in the
classroom not just in the classroom but
on the playground in the hallways it was
noticeable in chess they learn social
skills they learn how to work together
with each other they learn how to be
competitive in a positive environment so
it's an overall holistic approach to
teaching there was a large-scale
research study done in the
ferguson-florissant school district 4
2015 after the chest classes commenced
those kids had substantially more
positive feelings about school in a
broad sense and make me feel very happy
that I got the all play chess yung
Claire I got I got all courses the Vita
for me to help me come on the street and
quit again superstar I equate chest to
life all my boys I call them King and I
let them know you guys rule the game and
I let all the girls know you're the most
powerful piece on board so at the end of
the day we need all of you just to step
up it's about choices just like life
chances choices i'll move this piece
move that piece same thing with these
kids do i do the right thing or the
wrong thing you make the wrong move
whether its streets classroom whatever
it could hurt you and a lot of them are
there getting there slowly coming around
and like okay I see what
me I think there's probably room for
chess in some form or fashion in every
single one of our schools in our current
climate it's very difficult to bring in
some of these extras it's not something
that we have a budget for I think the
greatest challenge that we face at the
Chess Club today is the growth of our
scholastic chess programs as they see
these transformative moments in these
students lives they all lunch up without
community support without corporate
support we would not have a chess
program the way that we do now I think
all the schools should take the timeouts
or just invest in this you know it's
important a lot of times I think our
children aren't necessarily pushed into
things which are their strong suit from
just what I'm saying we have a lot of
good player a lot of potential and all
it is just getting them to understand
the rules and then let them be free
while they're playing the game